now that we've gone over these different
types of ideas I'd like you to hear
about a company and decide which of
these ideas apply to that company the
first company is called ship ship is a
company that allows users to send mail
and packages to anyone in the world
users can choose an item take a picture
of it on their phone and then set a
destination and schedule a pickup ship
takes care of the rest by picking up the
item in finding the lowest cost and most
reliable way to send the package pretty
seamless so which type of ideas do you
think apply to the company ship check
all of these idea types that you think
apply to the company